Mình sọ tháng tâm đồ biết phòng xân trà cho biết tự lượng bình phòng 2 quân cụ bà và chúng tâm tìm kiểm cố nạn hành hành bình em.
Đã trình khai nhiều tàu tìm kiểm linh tục, tương ngày mùng tâm hành tâm.
Hai trong xong muốn người gặp nạn ở đuất cứu và đu vào bờ ăn quan.
Hai người còn lại chưa được tìm thấy, dô kế tốt tìm kiểm chính thức.
Lương mời trương nạn nghe thông báo đến cái tổ cáo đồng trong khu vực đình y涯 tăng cường quan sát và hỗ trợ.
Thì và thiện dấu hiệu liên quan đến nạn nhân.
Trong ngày mì sọ tháng tâm, nhóm SOS quảng Nam cùng ra đình tý tục tổ chức tìm kiểm bằng 2 cano và một tổ cáo.
Tại khu vực cố là trăm và hòn trào.
ra đình một đần nhắn cũng sự kiến thôi thật lạc tìm kiểm thêm.
Tại khu vực các sạch đảm mũi hề.